what was it like for you to go from
you're making this very handheld like
it's a mod pod shop and you're making
your comedy and then you get you get
into something like Pacific Rim which is
one of those movies where I can't even
imagine because I can relate to you uh
in the world of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia and then when I think about
and and even playing a comedic role in a
movie but when I think about you in
something like when that first Pacific
Rim came out and you realize oh my God
it's such a good movie and you realize
that
your
um
you're part of an apparatus that is so
massive and you are it's the complete
other end of the spectrum yeah from the
kind of work that you were doing
and you did it really well thank you
well I think um I was lucky that I got
to have that transition working with
Guillermo del Toro so uh as massive as
that movie was
he has a way of working that makes it
feel you know super personal and
specific and uh
I had some green screen work but most of
the things that I was doing he had built
some kind of practical prop that was
like animatronic that I was you know
reacting to so
it wasn't quite like getting stuck into
like the Star Wars remakes where you
know maybe it's just all green screen
right right you're always acting to a
green sock or a green tennis ball yeah
and Gamo had a very very specific way of
working I was huge fan so I just wanted
to do a good job for him and I still
admire him so much and look up to him a
lot but uh you know in the beginning of
the film
he was saying he's like I want you to do
it I never do this I want you to be
loose and uh out of control and wild and
messy uh and by the end of the filming
it was like uh on thick one your aunt
was here on take two it was here
but that's just I mean I really enjoyed
getting to work within his parameters
sure yeah uh every now and then he I'd
be doing a take and he wouldn't be
liking what I was doing he'd be telling
me what to do and I'd be thinking oh boy
not giving him what he wants and then I
would throw it away and just do whatever
I wanted and be like yes like that you
know which is always sort of the case
that you have to make it your own but um
but it to me it was eye-opening just uh
the way he used the camera and I'm a big
movie nerd so I was just geeking out on
on his techniques he he was saying
he was like I like to scratch the lens
for the CGI shot I'm like scratch the
lens he's like I want you to see I don't
maybe it's wrong to do an impersonation
of him every time but he was saying I
want you to see something imperfect
before you see the Perfection of CGI the
way his mind was working
uh I was just eating it all up and then
I would go back to Sunny uh and we'd be
shooting I remember we did a uh episode
where we're in a police station and it's
a flashback and we're talking about this
wedding Massacre that happened with
people were high on bath salts and I was
saying okay when we shoot it you know
we'll we'll do the coverage uh that
Richie Keane great director had sort of
um blocked out but I said hey Richie
after we get that can we do a few
Guillermo takes and just circle the
camera around the actors and just
started using more as I would call them
Guillermo takes throughout the show
and um
it just getting more and more inspired
to do more filming and make more things
the only uh the thing that would be
dangerous there is I know that in a
comedy environment you can take for
that like you just came back from your
Guillermo del Toro Blockbuster and
you're back with your friends and you're
like you know what we did on Pacific Rim
you know and then suddenly you're right
back in Rhode Island yeah yeah yeah
exactly
uh fortunately I think Robin Glenn our
relationship is not like that so uh you
know pretty much best idea wins in a
pretty open environment for let's try
all sorts of things so I everyone was
was game for it